So, how are lists different from strings?
You saw that both support indexing,
slicing, and the in operator.
The most obvious difference is that strings are sequences of letters,
while list elements can be any type of object.
Or more subtle difference is that lists can be modified but strings can't.
Here, we can change the fourth element index three of this list to Friday, if you want.
But here, we get an error if we tried to change the third element of a string.
The technical term for whether an object can be
modified after its creation is mutability.
We can modify the values of lists.
So, a list is an mutable data type.
We can't modify strings,
so a string is an immutable data type.
As we introduce more data types,
there are two factors that we will continue to consider.
One is mutability, and the other is order.
Order is whether the order of contents for an object matters,
and whether or not, part of the object can be accessed using this order.
Both strings and lists are ordered,
which is why indexing works well for them.
However, one is mutable while the other is not.
We will see more data types that fall under
different sections of this grid as we continue.
For now, we'll explore the methods and functions that work on lists,
and we'll take advantage of list mutability in our programs.